plan de relance il va être inclus pour
l'essentiel des mesures dans le projet
de loi de finances pour 2021 ce qui
d'ailleurs pose un problème parce que
nous ne pourrons engager des crédits
qu'à partir du mois de janvier prochain
voilà pourquoi j'ai évoqué avec le
premier ministre il ya deux semaines
l'hypothèse de décret d'avancé puis j'ai
évoqué un deuxième sujet si on ne
déconcentre pas une part importante de
ces crédits en direction des territoires
la relation préfet entreprises la
relation préfet collectivités
territoriales je le dis à ce micro on
fera le bilan dans un an si on ne le
fait pas on n'aura même pas consommer 50
% des crédits du plan de relance alors
qu'il faut plus qu'un plan il faut un
choc de relance
c'est ce dont notre pays a besoin c'est
par exemple les orientations générales
ou paraissent bonnes a oui c'est pas un
choc de relance allez vous dire 100
milliards ça ne vous semble pas baisser
la mise en oeuvre d'un grand département
au delà de la noce quand vous mettez en
oeuvre concrètement des soutiens la
sécurité c'est pas un sentiment c'est
une réalité
alors je connais toutes les bagarres de
chief ce que c'est simplement c'est
qu'en 20 ans des violences contre c'est
positif de l'autorité qui étaient autour
de 15500 parents sont plus que doublé à
38 milles et que quand vous êtes dans le
quartier des izards à toulouse vous
quand vous interrogez les gens de
bressuire je fais référence à nos
confrères aujourd'hui le sentiment
d'insécurité c'est pas le sentiment
c'est une réalité vécue au quotidien
alors deux choses nous attendons depuis
deux ans une loi de programmation sur la
sécurité il faut intervenir à chaque
fois pour éviter les violences
il faut en même temps et c'est pour ça
que l'idée de superviseur comme le
faisait les gendarmes mobiles auprès des
policiers dans l'utilisation d'un
certain nombre j'allais dire
d'instruments comme le lanceur de balles
tout ceci m'apparaît être des décisions
il faudra naturellement évaluer mais
indispensable parce qu' est-ce que ou si
on a plus on si on a le sentiment de
l'état impuissant
c'est le cas quand vous regardez
grenoble comme regarder paris quand vous
regardez un certain nombre de quartiers
et en plus de l'impunité des délinquants
alors vous avez une perte totale de
confiance et ceux ci participent à la
défiance collective que je sens vraiment
dans le pays andin je n'ai rien en
commun avec le rassemblement national
et si je me bats pour cet espace
politique entre la république en marche
elle rassemblement national c'est pour
dire clairement les choses
elle est dire extrêmement clairement à
nos concitoyens
je pense qu'il ya une alternative
politique que nous pouvons incarner moi
j'ai envie de reconstruire
j'allais dire une confiance nous sommes
un pays fracturé entre urbains et ruraux
métropole villes moyennes et petites
communes vous savez on se redressa
passera pas sans la confiance